Працював на полі і не чув, як почалася війна.
Робітник Слов’янської психіатричної лікарні
Сергій Сафаров
ніколи не забуде 5-те травня 2014-ого.
Тоді лікарня вперше опинилася під перехресними артобстрілами.
Сергій отримав поранення ноги.
Зі мною було четверо людей.
Одного вбили, царство йому небесне.
Мені першу допомогу надала Тетяна,
тільки не знаю, як її прізвище.
Медики діставалися до поранених плазуючи,
тягли їх назад у будівлю.  А ще, сюди постійно
везли поранених військових. На щастя,
жоден із двохсот пацієнтів не постраждав.
Паніки вдалося уникнути. Хворим просто розповіли,
що тривають навчання і треба спуститися у бомбосховище.
От в цих кімнатах
під час обстрілів лікарі переховувалися разом з пацієнтами.
Наприкінці цього літа -
принаймні в цьому корпусі дитячого відділення -
тут уже нічого не має нагадувати про війну. Корпус став другим
з 8-ми зруйнованих будівель лікарні,
де проводять реконструкцію.
Перший корпус - для хворих на туберкульоз - вже відбудували.
Втілення проекту координують інженери Червоного хреста з Люксембургу,
а фінансує реконструкцію уряд Німеччини.
Вартість проекту - сімсот тисяч євро.
Ми просто хочемо допомогти людям.
Якщо в  них проблеми зі здоров'ям,
щоб їм могли фахово допомогти.
Зокрема внутрішні переселенці пережили багато драматичних моментів
і потребують психологічної підтримки.
Наразі психіатричне відділення у Слов'янську
тимчасово розміщене в одному з приміщень
колишнього санаторію.
З часу початку бойових дій -
найбільше пацієнтів  з психологічними травмами, завданими війною.
Поступає більше хворих. Більше стали звертатися.
Відчувається от цей післявоєнний синдром.
Німці допоможуть слов’янській лікарні також з обладнанням,
аби лікарня якнайшвидше знову запрацювала.
У державних планах щодо відновлення Донбасу
передбачено понад двісті мільйонів гривень
на реконструкцію ще трьох корпусів лікарні
до 2020 року.
Поки ж виділено лише  близько чотирьох мільйонів.